je vois dans la vie d'un journaliste et
représente un journal qui à mon avis
doit croire à certaines valeurs auquel
charlie hebdo n'a jamais cru jean
bourdier de minutes
quelle était votre réactiver votre
réaction sur ce journal et sur sa mort
oui tour de partie parce que je suis
toujours désolé de voir crever un
journal parce que j'en ai vu trop crevé
et qu'il n'était pas en place et alors
un corps quand je parlais nice ne parle
esteban à part la minute près 20
bon eh bien tant mieux chez ravi parce
que vous amener mon deuxième propos qui
va venir en son temps je précise que
quand je parle de journal je ne parle
pas du bulletin d'information mauvais
salle de lurs j'ai nommé l'humanité je
parle d'un vrai journal
bon charlie hebdo était moi
personnellement je trouvais pas ça
follement drôle je n'étais pas du tout
client même pas regardeur sauf pour le
fameux bal trajet tragique à colombey un
mort et qui m'a beaucoup amusé d'autant
que il aura fallu dix ans la minus
[ __ ] jnane en signer douze ans pelé
allons en silence il a rien que nous
avons nous avons ici la démonstration du
comportement des gens qui sont pour la
liberté d'esprit tout cas je ne suis pas
par la liberté d'esprit nous laisser
finir laisser finir en tenant non
attendez je demande un peu de silence
sept minutes normalement et mai
pour faire croire mais alors écoutez non
je peux pas rouler rouler parce que ça
drôle
je vous demande de me laisser faire
cette émission je fais les missions vous
n'êtes pas là ce tirage est allée baco
minutes existe seront je suis désolé je
revendique que minutes existe mais je
doute existe sans vie je revendique la
raillerie existe écoutez pour l'instant
le board il n'a rien pu dire alors
laissez le terminer parce que la
démocratie cdc chacun parlait alors jean
bourdier on tombe jean bourdaillet
laisser parler en bourbier
alors je regrette de voir périr un
journal je suis content allemand et
péter fût ce que tu as quelques
interruptions silence et
non écouter respecter un minimum de
règles du jeu sens à cette émission on
fera la preuve qu'on ne peut pas la
faire
alors jean mortier albert moche je suis
disposé à m'emballer sombrer dans la
bassine avec cantine et c'est tout parce
que je regrette j'ai entendu à des
propos nous sommes des incompris et
quand un journaliste paraît il est
d'abord un compris de ses lecteurs c'est
tout le monde a reconnu mais au lieu de
se demander pourquoi on est incompris de
ses lecteurs j'ai vu des gens qui est
anglais
les gens qui ne les lisez pas pourquoi
ça je ne comprends pas je ne comprends
pas l'attitude de l'équipe de charlie
hebdo à l'égard jaune des lycéens
vénitien disait bon on le lit peut on ne
lit pas du tout voilà nos raisons au
lieu de les écouter et de respecter leur
opinion après tous ces grands partisans
de la liberté d'opinion les engueuler où
je ne comprends pas cette attitude
et quand l'on journal ne se vendra plus
je veux dire est que c'est moi qui suis
en tort et pas les lecteurs que j'aurais
pu avoir c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
bon merci jean bourdier réponse de de
kavanagh c'est exactement ce que j'ai
dit c'est exactement ce qu'ils me disent
que si on était plus c'est qu'on les ait
plus haut les soeurs et qui
au total on a évoqué avec l'équipe et
s'endort métro déjà je voulais froissée
mais ne vont pas bien sûr c'est ça qui
est bien tout à fait inadmissible et
fraîche transparence alors écoutez bon
écoutez on va vous calmer tous un petit
peu on va vous envoyer à dessin animé de
mort d'ions c'est absolument charmant on
va se calmer un instant alors mordille
haut nous avons un dessin bon est-ce
qu'on peut envoyer ce dessin animé de
mauguio histoire de se calmer je
voudrais bien qu'on respecte une règle
du jeu
et pour ça il faudrait peut-être un
petit peu d'ordre sur le plateau parce
que on peut pas compter
bien c'est moi qui l'ait fait oui non
mais j'ai donné une carte blanche à
l'équipe de charlie hebdo mais
j'espérais que mon bien élevé